今天想跟大家聊一個，聽起來很不可思議，但其實很值得深思的案例。烏克蘭戰場上的無人機數據，你覺得它最後的歸宿會是什麼？大概就是一些軍事情報分析吧？
沒錯啊，當然是拿來分析戰況，或是訓練下一代的軍事裝備。畢竟那是最前線的情報，機密性那麼高，怎麼可能流到外面去。
這就是出乎意料的地方了。烏克蘭國防部居然把這些數據，開放給民間公司，甚至英國政府也能取得。而且這不是做慈善，是賣數據。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說賣數據？那都是戰場上殘骸的數據，影像、飛行路徑、控制指令這些，怎麼會有商業價值？而且誰會想買啊？
他們的數據現在被看作是「新金礦」。烏克蘭國防部在今年一月宣布，要把數萬次無人機飛行所產生的數百萬數據點，提供給軍事承包商和商業公司。到現在已經有超過 100 家公司和英國政府取得。
這些公司買了能幹嘛？難道拿去訓練送貨無人機，讓它學會在砲火中穿梭嗎？這也太…不切實際了吧。
原文有提到一個關鍵，最能訓練 AI 模型的是「例外狀況」的數據。比如說，能見度突然消失、訊號被干擾，或者操作員臨時應變的瞬間。
一般的 AI 公司為了收集這些「例外」，要花很多時間跟金錢在實驗室模擬。但戰場上的混亂，卻以極高的頻率產生這些寶貴的數據，是實驗室很難重現的。
噢，我好像有點懂了。等於是把戰場變成一個超大型的實境實驗室，而且這些極端狀況的數據，在民用領域也能派上用場。比如說，送貨無人機在惡劣天氣或訊號不穩的環境下，也需要這些應變能力。
就是這個意思。原文也說，一架商用無人機在送貨或遙測時，雖然不會遇到砲火，但也必須在資訊不完整、人類行為難以預測的世界中運作。戰場數據剛好把這些問題壓縮在更短的時間線裡。
那這模式能撐多久？烏克蘭戰爭總有結束的一天吧？結束了，這些數據還有什麼用？這算是一次性的生意，還是長期的商業模式？
其實這數據的價值會「遠遠超過」戰爭本身。一家美國公司 Enabled Intelligence，專門處理這些數據讓它能用在 AI 訓練。他們已經將超過 50 萬小時的烏克蘭無人機錄影，提供給下一代模型訓練。
哇，50 萬小時！這個數字真的很有說服力。所以說，這些數據不僅能訓練軍用系統，也能回流到農業、物流這些民生產業？
沒錯，舉例來說，在烏克蘭受過訊號干擾空域訓練的無人機，現在已經部署到農業部門，幫助農民測繪田地，特別是在那些缺乏手機訊號的地方，過去的技術都做不到。
所以這不只是一個單純的數據買賣，更像是一個「數據閉環」的概念。商用技術變成軍用，在戰場上收集到極端狀況的數據，然後這些數據又回流，優化了原本的商業技術。
是的，而且這個數據現在不再只侷限在軍事情報界。以前像捕食者、死神這類無人機的數據，都只在國防世界內部流通。現在這個迴圈擴大了，讓更廣泛的開發網路都能使用。
這點其實不容易做到，因為牽涉到國家機密和安全問題。烏克蘭這麼做，應該也是為了吸引資金和合作夥伴，在戰時快速發展。
他們也確實做到了。原文提到，對一個正在戰爭的國家來說，這是一種吸引資金和夥伴的快速方式。但同時，也把前線變成一個活躍的模型訓練場。
我想到一件事，如果我是開一家小吃店的，生意不好的時候，那些失敗的菜色、客人抱怨的紀錄，是不是也可以被重新檢視，變成一種「例外狀況」的數據？或許能從中找到新的菜單靈感或經營方式？
對啊，或者上班族在工作中遇到的挫折、失敗的專案經驗，與其就這樣丟掉，不如好好分析裡面的「例外狀況」，是什麼導致失敗？如何應變？說不定能從中萃取出提升工作效率或解決問題的新方法。
這樣聽起來，好像任何「負面」的，甚至是被視為「無用」的邊角數據，只要換個角度看，都可能變成有價值的東西。只是我們習慣了往正面、成功的經驗裡找答案。
確實如此。這個案例好像也提醒了我們，即使在最極端的環境下，那些看似無用的殘骸，也能被重新定義，創造出意想不到的商業價值。